oh il a dit avant qu'ils ne fassent un manuel de
construction que vous prenez ici ou le
seul album arisia ancien seul Russie
unka ma société ouais après Walker ceci
oui la slovénie slovène le deuxième
hélicoptère pourquoi l'Union et le vol
Afrique africa's kannada Det je vois DJ
marcher  apres avant inde duplexer ma
compagnie 60 un helicoptere ceesar
ce que le nom de la compagnie arrive en
185 helicoptere un pays tant 185
ou votre compagnie helicoptere oui 185 zone
Alicia 185 ellicott ou la Volusia
185 autre United Nation 1 z attention
toi
oui ça  des coups dans certaines preuves ici de
la fusée éclairante prétendent qu'ils auront une
autre claire qui entrera il s'applique
vraiment
je me suis couvert
je vais je vais je veux tirer pour
l'autre côté regarde sauf mais des bogues se
déplaçant ici vous pensez que le BD bogue
ici je ne sais pas regarde je moyen de me mettre
hors service pour pointer tout droit
je vais nommer une visite à la dernière minute oui
oui oui oui oui je suppose que j'ai dit oh
je pensais avoir vu ce conseil vous  si je sais
que c'est enterré dans l'apopka veda allez au fond de
six merci juste une étagère de nos
trous d'épingle maintenant ils ne laissent pas le pays hôte que
nous ferons vous faire comme vous aussi d'
accord devrions-nous prendre d'autres photos
autour du nuage au-dessus des nuages
regarde en arrière tout ce qu'il a aimé cette mise à jour un peu
ennuyeuse Oh Carly le vol trois personnes
trois d'épaisseur alors tu me dis quoi faire est
cet amour reste juste à cette hauteur pendant un
petit moment ne me perce pas ce que tu
veux faire parce que nous sommes  va yak à
nous expulser pour aller à l'intérieur du nuage pour avoir
à mettre des gens ouais toujours venir
au soleil les
gens poids libre à ça hein ouais tout
le chemin ouais je sais que je dirais ça mais
je vais juste rester là il y a un
chaussette ça arrive n'a pas de noël arrive
oh c'est tout à coup bien c'est ouais
je pense que je sens les trois vrais rapidement
j'ai besoin de changer bien mais j'ai dit que je t'ai eu
mec ouais ouais ça va faire exploser
un changement les gens  sommes-nous à l'intérieur du
développement devenons les nôtres si vous ne le faites pas,
c'est de l'exportation  ed absolument d'accord
ça me fait plus de 30 autres si vous devez faire je
pense que nous devons faire en Italie chaque
été comme je reste déjà éveillé et
enlève la couleur et puis Oh yella qu'est-ce que
le club d'accord me dit que le chef est les
palettes de couleurs c'est  parti, il ne sera pas
préparé pour le futur bébé, arrêtez simplement d'
enregistrer et guidé vers Dale pour vous entendre,
puis nous avons de l'huile sous nous en
dessous, je vois déjà que jouer
un autre nuage
bbel était la seule autre façon de
vaincre le père
est  une flambée de pétrole l'autre jour,
la montée à nouveau Verizon
40 pieds par seconde que nous avons vu est la meilleure quand je suis
corazon je pense que je rap aussi laissez-moi commencer
nos propres gens sont des gens que je veux aller
dans le placard à cette conversion chante d'
accord nous sommes  en partant du satellite la
chambre à coucher Cesar cloud si bien je pense qu'il
faut être un bon encore une fois la configuration dans l'
autre sens pour voler quand vous arrivez
pour voir le reflet et j'ai plus l'
image habituelle nous faisons qu'en pensez-vous
qu'en pensez-vous je  ça t'a donc on
se retourne on c  un coup en retour ou d'accord oui
mais tu sais d'accord Eddie euh tu dois
faire ça sur le nuage tu ok porque soy
nada vois cette clarté au milieu
de l'image fais un peu peur que quand
ils existent c'est plus tu sais que
ça va  ne sois pas bon écoute ouais
ok ok skype pour les trois en haut de ça
vraiment comme si tu jouais détermine
lequel lequel nous nous détendons juste autour des
premières choses que tu as faites autour et fais la
queue ok ok la bombe ok
chuchote à expulser  Je ouais celui qui
m'a jeté celui qui me laisse vous remercier mrs.
la caméra roule toujours euh parce que le club
est sur ses talons ou quoi faire à part
aussi tourner à gauche tourner à gauche alors je ce soir
si 10 frappe un couple de live live live
ici c'est pas occupé nuage une belle journée
ouais trop beau grimpeur trop plus
clair  Je vais beaucoup jouer alors je nuit
c'est le x où les caméras pointent
en ce moment c'est un bon coup qui est
ce trop gros comme ouais il faut être
comme je vais être parti pour arriver à chaque coucher de soleil que
nous vivons j'adore voir le reflet  tu
sais Donna tu sais ce que je veux dire ouais je
que se mais nous avons eu une fusée éclairante pour commencer
dans oh oui bla mais tu sais je pense que
c'était pour le ramasser tu vois aussi comme
tout à coup tu sais ouais
encore je kristen est là tu as dit  à
Delta 3 ou 3 2 delta dans l'ensemble d'
accord j'adore ça au filtre 2d dépend de moi
comme vous voyez c'est le lac vers
moi d'accord c'est envoyé tout droit
ici si j'attends attends attends attends on
va à l'intérieur et après nous  descends
tu m'as dit ce que tu veux faire
ouais c'est un nuage r  ight here ok
Hector out passe par celui-là ok ok
ne peut pas non plus montrer au pilote focus ce
désespoir est celui-ci tu vas tu vas à l'intérieur
celui-ci celui-ci celui-ci ok ok celui-
ci ça ira mais ça fait un peu de cul
changer avec non il n'y a pas de progrès c'est
bien ouais c'est bien les bons gars en ce
moment très gentil très gentil Ryan les yeux sont
très gentils très gentils hé gentil je suis en plastique
fantastique parfait parfait pluie la prochaine
verticalement ici allez à l'intérieur de celui-ci
je suis  donc c'est nous en lire un puis on rentre dans
l'ombre
euh d'accord les deux vont se débarrasser de la
dentelle mais ils ont dit je m'inquiète pour le
jeu probablement on ne voit pas très bien tu
sais bien il y a trop de nuage tu
sais c'est quelque chose de bien en partie
nuageux ensoleillé Espagne nous sommes aussi trop mauvais
l'autre mec ce que tu veux faire là-bas
nous descendons avec n'importe quelle raison je dis que nous
ne pouvons pas le faire aujourd'hui d'accord oh je ne rentre pas
parce que tu as du soleil que tu peux voir sur
le sol  mais ils ont été forts
ouais je veux dire oh c'est délicat c'est ça tu
sais tu ne sais pas quoi  t vous devez vous rendre
au tunnel, c'est difficile de planifier d'accord
bon ouais et si nous savons que nous voulions faire
ce genre de plans, nous trouverons d'autres
endroits pour les faire bon chanteur à faire à
chaque fois que nous devons apprendre le nouvel
endroit où nous devons  essayez de faire ouais d'accord ou
rappelez-vous que c'est que d'
accord arrêtez d'enregistrer pour mon dieu à
quelle distance de l'aéroport devrions-
nous penser à riposter maintenant quand
je l'ai emmenée aux urgences, nous avons pris le relais il y a une
heure comme j'écris k  tu plaisantes vérifier d'
accord tout le monde devient réel pour de toute façon d'
accord
célébrité qu'il pourrait venir pour
le personnel ildren la façon dont un à 11
roue de filtre on est tu veux l'arrêter
hahaha essaie juste d'essayer rapidement la justice souhaite juste le
numéro 11 c'est euh c'est un gros  mentir je
paierai plus avez-vous trouvé votre
pichet de filtre numérique 56a ouais ouais ouais un
peu trop euh sans contact
déféqué ouais d'accord j'arrête